qui est là pour Pulido a dit que nous avons vu
des médecins pour les yeux noirs,
mon personnage est un magicien dans un
cirque itinérant,
il est emmené dans ce monde magique
appelé Oz et tous les gens de ce nouveau
monde pensent qu'il est un vrai sorcier avec de
vrais pouvoirs magiques le pays de  Oz sa
plus grande échelle au fur et à mesure qu'elle est sous la
direction de Sam Raimi est juste un
cinéaste incroyable Je n'ai jamais aimé quelqu'un d'
aussi passionné que lui Sam a une
imagination enfantine incroyable c'est
une très grande image le monde d'Oz est
franc baum créé il a tellement  de nombreux
pays différents c'est un monde entier le
concepteur de production robert stromberg a
créé une version originale et
époustouflante du pays d'Oz Robert est venu d'
Avatar et d'Alice au pays des merveilles et a remporté des
Oscars pour les deux il y avait une
vraie route de briques jaunes et mon château
était comme un  conte de fées mais c'était
complet c'était juste devant mes
yeux il était si con tu as parlé de titre
Monsieur mais tu n'agis pas nous avons commencé
très précisément avec  chacune des
sorcières que nous préparions également en même temps
Oz comme vêtements et vraiment j'ai
réalisé que je n'avais jamais connu
la joie de travailler dans un pays de pure
fantaisie c'est juste un frisson que
nous avons réservé Liban e-even bonté mais la
fin de  Lundi alors Shion comment je burger a fait
un design brillant pour la méchante sorcière
de l'ouest
tout de suite Sam a jeté de côté les
trucs subtils non non c'est la sorcière je veux une
grande sorcière verte effrayante Howard Berger est
un artiste incroyable et il m'a certainement donné
un  la direction pour créer le reste des
personnages, chaque personne d'arrière-plan a
été personnellement conçue les cheveux et
le costume, le maquillage à tous les égards, c'est
s'il était censé être sur cette personne qui a
été une tâche assez
incroyable pour faire cela, je pense qu'il y en a
des surprises attendent sur la
route de briques jaunes,
c'est tellement magique que c'est un film que
vous pouvez emmener avec toute votre famille, les
téléspectateurs découvriront un
monde fantastique et une belle histoire que
vous